other and welcome to this session on
where to store your stuff with Google
cloud platform my name is David Nelson
I'm a product manager here at Google
cloud I've been here for about four
years now and been working on storage
throughout that time and what I'm going
to do today and it's covered two main
topics really so first of all just maybe
stand back a little bit and go through a
history of how storage is evolved how
databases have evolved and then walk
through from there some of the options
that are available over cloud for
storing your data before I get to that
though quick safe harbor and a statement
just to remind folks that some of the
announcements that I might talk about in
here a forward-looking and a bear that
in mind from a safe harbor perspective
so first of all let me start with a
history of storage and and you know if I
go back you know 30 40 50 years the way
that storage first came about was really
your storage physically attached to the
computer right so on the left hand side
here does this notion of sort of
direct-attached storage storage is
physically attached to the computer that
you're using the storage is really there
only to be used for the local machine
and as the local data and it's all very
physically connected often into a single
piece of hardware with a monitor that
somebody would then sit at and we'll go
back a long way for this but this is
classic direct-attached storage also you
know the common PC would also look like
this as well but then as as people
wanted to think about sharing their data
more um they started to think about what
does data and storage look like over a
network and this involved in a number of
different ways so one way in which this
involved evolved is to take take the
storage move just the storage over a
network leave a file the file system
local to the machine or the computer on
which you're using and have block
storage
be remote over the network block storage
was the preferred model here because it
would give good remote performance the
file system would be local on the
computer it would use large block sizes
8 8 K 16 K block sizes or even larger 64
K to communicate remotely over the
network sending large IO requests to
bring data back and forward and it would
cache what it would need locally and
this really was the area of sort of
storage area networks where companies
could start a consolidate storage from
individual machines started consolidated
into a central pool of storage and
managed high-performance block storage
centrally and deliver it to the
applications that need it over the
network so that was pretty good for sort
of some of the high performance use
cases where you need the local
performance on the on the machine but
what it didn't work so well is is if you
wanted to share files between different
users in an organization for that the
classic file share or the network
attached storage and was the storage
option that evolved for that so it's
file storage file sharing over a network
here the V file system is remote it's
all across the network from the compute
or the application that's using it and
the file system is available and to all
users to be able to connect to it use it
and share let's greet from a sharing
perspective one of the challenges with
that though is as customers start to as
users in an organization start to share
and use many files then you know lots of
complexity start to rise in terms of who
can access what file who's allowed to
read it who can write it what are the
Commission's around that and then
managing folders and hierarchies and
scaling the metadata storage means the
building large scale scalable high
performance file systems is a really big
hard challenging problem but super
powerful in that it's very easy to there
applications share file data between
many different applications and then so
that was really the story how storage
evolved for very many years and then a
final class of storage has emerged more
recently and actually probably
popularized in the cloud first first and
foremost which was object storage so
here the goal is to be able to store
really large amounts unstructured data
so I think videos or pictures images
started really cheaply and a really
really large scale as I said that's
something that really sort of came to
fruition in the public cloud first where
customers would look for a cheap easy
way to store flexibly large amounts of
data and then access it often
occasionally to get access to that and
you know this model made some very big
trade-offs right it it had a very simple
API there wasn't a lot of sharing
between users of the data it's often
upend openly admit that it made
trade-offs to be able to support that
storing lot at storing large amounts of
data remotely and being able to access
it in a very simple API and a new API
which was the object API was brought
into was brought about in order to do
that
so if I if I'm at these sort of
different classes or types of storage
now to what is available in the cloud
you know the the evolution of the
classic storage being tightly coupled to
the application and the file system and
compute is available so this is classic
block storage is available in two forms
in Google cloud platform first of all we
have persistent disk in a standard and
SSD format which lets you remotely mount
a block storage device or a disk at T or
vm in Google cloud platform that disk is
durable able to withstand restarts of
the p.m. and and high performance in
addition we have a protocol local SSD
which is a ephemeral storage is attached
very much directly to the actual
physical compute instance that is
much much higher performance from it but
it's but it's ephemeral alright so those
are the two block storage solutions that
we have available in Google Cloud today
for now network attached storage all
right a file share where I want a store
have a file share which shared in a
department or across my enterprise and
from Google Cloud we have Google Cloud
file store as our first party product
and then we also work closely with very
very well with partners such as NetApp
dilip del emc particular Isilon their
excellent product and ddn and these are
enterprise vendors who've been working
in this in the area of file storage for
very many years now and many customers
have been working with them and we want
to make sure we can help carry those
customers forward as they look to use
those products in the cloud and then for
object storage in Google Cloud the
product we have there is called a cloud
storage and that's our object storage
product which lets you store a data at
really large scale I'll go through the
inde down some more on the Google cloud
products that we have available later
end of the presentation um so let me
also talk about you know or the other
places in Google cloud that you might
product and Google cloud that you might
use to store data and let's talk about
databases and so at a high level you
know for many years the world of
databases there's sort of a very
traditional model that lasted for many
years so the late 60s 70s that classic
relational database where you would
store a record in a in a table a row
would be stored in the table and you can
join it together with other rows and
other tables really introduced a very
powerful model for managing storing and
reasoning about about data and the
traditional relational database
management market grew to be you know a
very very large business with IBM and
Oracle leading way and grew into a very
large traditional on-premises industry
then and you know the benefit of this
was that you could do really fast
reasoning of a small amounts of data and
store it pretty quickly
if you wanted to run large queries for
analytics do reporting or in a dashboard
it was normally it's pretty bad practice
to be to run those queries against the
same system that's running you know your
banking application so quite often data
would be moved off of the database
system into a data warehouse by a
process known as ETL extract extract
transform load and data would be copied
over into a data warehouse it would be
rearranged in a particular way to make
it really easy to do large-scale
analytics and reporting and that and
that combination of database and data
warehouse really has stood the test of
time for for many years and it still
remains the bastion of many sort of
enterprise organizations is data storage
and analytics processing and so really
that that that ecosystem existed for a
long time and then and then over you
know towards the start over there you
know through that 2000s there was a
whole there's a number of different
trends that started to affect how well
that ecosystem could scale so first and
foremost was the emergence of just
really large amounts of unstructured
data with more devices connected with
the emergence of the Internet and with
different types of data being generated
the traditional relational database
management system just simply could not
cope with that amount of storage anymore
and the amount of analytics that needed
to run over it so several types of kind
of more specialized systems started to
emerge probably the most one of most
famous of those is that is Hadoop which
is a large scale analytics platform for
unstructured data that lets you gather
large amounts of data really cheaply
ruin large amounts of batch processing
over it and then and do Anna do analysis
on that and that really you know really
changed the dynamic of how people
thought about doing analytics and
there's a big debate you know should
they get rid of my warehouse and put
everything in a data lake or everything
she during the day lake or everything
goes in my data warehousing in reality
both of these systems are perfectly good
working side by
side and often customers will store
nater in a daily wake for their initial
capture and then load it eventually into
into a warehouse but who came along as a
really interesting trend and set of
capabilities to help customers more
easily get data value out of that one
structured data within the more semi
structured structured world to other
things also happened as well so
customers would also look hey I've got a
really large amount sparse data's of key
values I want to do lookups I'm
gathering records of data which is semi
structured and I've got a really large
amount of it coming out of my IOT system
for example it's it's anything so cell
tower data is pretty well structured
there's fifteen sixteen different types
of data maybe in a in a record but
that's evolving over time there's really
large amounts of sparse key value lookup
data and that again it's not something
that's particularly well-suited for a
traditional database system because of
the scale that it wants to operate at
and the cost trade-offs take it in a
slightly different direction and then in
addition you know as we also saw trends
and more semi structured data storage
things like being able to start JSON
documents and do reasoning over those as
people starting to capture data in JSON
formats and so they went to another two
types of databases which are key value
databases and hierarchical databases is
two or the kind of classic new sequel
databases this is the category of
databases that you know they don't have
often the same deep transact trend
traditional semantics are the acid
properties of traditional relational
database management systems and then
they're willing to make trade-offs in
terms of their scale and other factors
in order to better support reasoning
over different forms of data and then
finally and most recently we're also now
seeing a class of databases that are
really large scale scale out
database management systems so the
traditional relational database
management system is a scale up system
so you'll put your database on on a
server you'll attach a load of storage
to it and if you want to store more
records or you want to do more compute
you gotta add more processors to that
same machine or you gonna add more disks
to that array right and so it was a
classic scale-up system and that runs
into some challenge is that you know
customers are buying bigger and bigger
systems to operate larger and larger
scale and that becomes very expensive
and not always very flexible and in
terms of where you can deploy that you
can only deploy it in a single location
and so now more recently there's a class
of database systems which let you now
store records transactionally at global
scale and and manage really large scale
transactional database systems I mean if
I go through the Google cloud products
that are available across this portfolio
so first of all the traditional database
we have the cloud sequel and set of
products from my sequel Postgres and
sequel server that let you run it
manager a database the query is our data
warehouse product for a data like Google
Cloud Data proc and cloud storage give
you data proc for managing computing and
cloud storage is your data week and then
BigTable provides key value storage
files
firestar for hierarchical data and in
cloud spanner is our database for a
really large-scale global transactional
databases so without overview in mind I
just thought I'd have a slide here that
should give you a rough mapping of the
different types of storage options that
are available to you depending on what
it is that you are looking to do with
Google cloud now let me maybe just dive
into the sort of the ones that are on
the right side there the storage
products I'll I'll leave the database
overviews to sort of the sessions and
I'm just going
concentrate and go through some of the
storage options that are available on
GCP so first of all Google Cloud Storage
so this is our large scale object
storage product customers are normally
using this for three different use cases
and so content storage and delivery so
if you want to store large amounts of
media video images and serve them out to
customers or store them for later
analysis Google Cloud Storage is a
really great product for that Christmas
like Spotify use this for storing
serving media content for example backup
archive ldr so a very common use case
where you have a set of data on-premises
that you're looking to protect you want
to store it remotely on a different
media to protect yourself against a
disaster either a physical disaster or
you know someone accidentally deleting
some data on premises and you want to be
able to recover it by a backup process
and so Google Cloud Storage is
integrated with very many backup and dr
products from our partners and is
available to use for a backup archival
and dr and there and then the final use
case is analytics big data in ml so I
talked about that the use case where
customers are wanting store really large
amounts of unstructured data for
processing and they want somewhere to
store that cheaply and the cloud is a
great place to do that they can use
something like Google Cloud storage to
store the data
super cheaply and then because compute
and storage is separate from each other
customers can store their data and when
they want to run a Hadoop cluster over
it they can just spin that cluster up
run it for the amount of time that's
needed and then shut it down this is a
huge value over the alternative
on-premises which is often trying to
size compute and storage together in a
single piece of equipment often having
to deal with planning for peak capacity
and and then trying to run it to make
sure that if in quiet times that you
know you know wasting capacity and so it
takes away a lot of that challenges with
trying to optimize the your TCO for a
cluster on-premises so with the cloud
you can
separate compute from storage use only
what you need on storage use only what
you need for compute and run those
independently and the product we have
Google Cloud Storage super powerful for
those use cases couple of things I'll
highlight there with this is we have a
number of different tiers from standard
near line cold line all the way down to
archival and these just give you
different ways to pay for how you store
your data something that's really
interesting about the product and very
differentiated is that across all of
those different tiers it's the same API
and the same access speeds to the data
so you don't need to change anything in
your application to be able to take
advantage of tearing data down cheaper
and cheaper storage classes if you don't
need to if your data doesn't need to be
accessed but if all of a sudden that
kinton movie the super popular five
years ago suddenly picks up again well
it's right there and immediately
available for access even if it might be
in an archive tiers no staging it back
from a different storage product that
has to bring it back to take a few hours
to stage it back to your main storage
tiers so that's a couple of benefits for
storage in general and then a few other
things specific to use cases so we have
four common storage and delivery
globally edge cache data and accelerate
uploads our data coming in from Europe
and stored in the US will bring it onto
the Google cloud network as soon as
possible and carry it on the network for
as long as possible until they serve it
with big data analytics where they do
all of the different readers in GCS will
see the same data so one one one of the
great features of Google Cloud Storage
is that it actually uses spanner which I
talked about is that trans actually
consistent database to store all of our
metadata so when somebody reads or when
something writes data or everybody else
can see the same data which is a big
benefit for Google's product here that's
actually pretty hard to do and it's
something that's super powerful and and
then as I talked about a little bit
earlier for backup D our archival across
all our storage classes
get instant access to the data no need
to stage access to the recovery and deal
with complicated workflows as to how
you're going to get access to your data
and then we have a couple of products in
the multi-regional category jewel
regional multi-regional which will store
your data in such a way that if a region
goes down then you can have it
immediately be able to read data
continue to read data from another copy
of the data in another region so
providing RTO a recovery time objective
of zero on failures if a region goes
down the multi region the dual region is
still available for reads and and you
can your application can continue
serving as though nothing has happened
persistent disks oposition disk is our
block storage product so here you're
really looking to attach a disk to VM
and run a whole range of applications
traditional sort of three-tier
applications or high-end database
applications or even Hadoop in big data
applications sometime run on this with
the performance and and we've positioned
this we have today we have two tiers
which is a standard tier and a high
performance tier and over the last year
we've steadily improved the performance
of those for example for a persistent
disk SSD we've steadily improved the i/o
options available for those tears from
60k two hundred thousand nine ops all
just as part of the product that was
available today will be we're now saying
some new tiers for SSD so feedback we
heard from customers was that while they
really enjoyed the sort of the easy to
use performance there's a couple of
trade-offs that they looked they found
hard to make with a product that we had
so what we want to do is introduce a new
tier that is as fewer as lower
performance and is better priced and
that's a new Balance tier that will be
available at ten cents a gig versus SSDs
current seventeen cents a gig and then
we're also going to introduce an extreme
tier for customers typically high end
database Chris was that one the very
highest performance starting with
120,000 die ups and eventually going up
from there and then of course all of
these products some things that are
really powerful about the system disk is
that it's just really easy really easy
to use and the disks can be dynamically
resized it can be easily moved around
between VMs you no need a stripe your
disks or pre-warm the disks to get the
maximum performance it's all that ready
and available on demand and one big
thing we focus on very hard in storage
at Google cloud is just making our
products really really easy to use for
customers so that you can focus on
building the applications and adding
value to your businesses and some of the
capabilities that we have high
availability backup India and so a high
availability you can create a regional
disk which creates a disks between two
different zones and actively create
active active replications of
synchronous replication between those
two disks which is super important if
you want to be able to build an
application that can survivor Luzerne
failure and recover quickly on the other
side typically for something like a
database and then we also have controls
for being able to take snapshots to
protect your data so you can take a disk
snapshot it the data restore it in a
different medium you can store that
snapshot in a different region you can
schedule snapshots so works well with
traditional backup and recovery
workforce and then fast also so as I
talked about a file store this is for
customers who are looking for a
traditional file share available as a
managed service and classic use cases
you know I want to share files in across
my organization I might be showing them
for video and image Annette editing by
destroying web content home directories
etc might be doing large-scale rendering
video and image editing and so with
milestone we offer fully managed
network-attached storage available in a
2 different tiers HDD and SSD tears
again goal here is to give really easy
to use easy to understand price
performance with really great
performance
very easy to use with both Google Cloud
engine for VMs and google kubernetes
engine for kubernetes another
announcement that we're very excited
about less than a year ago we acquired a
company called Alaska file which had a
really powerful set of scale out file
store had a very powerful
scale out file store file product and we
really excited to have that now
launching as a new tier of file store
called the high scale tier and this a
lot custom is scaled to hundreds of
terabytes tens of gigabytes of
throughput hundreds of thousands of iOS
and really help customers with some of
those large-scale web and high
throughput and media rendering batch
workloads so very excited about that and
then the phone where I want to cover so
is around transfer so having all of this
these capabilities in the cloud is great
but how am I gonna get my day to that so
customers come to as it may challenges
here sometimes they're shutting down
data centers move to the cloud sometimes
they want to do P or C sometimes they're
capturing large amounts of data for
analytics workloads IOT will close and
they want to bring that data to the
cloud we have two different products
available for customers here transfer of
clients so this is a physical appliance
that you can order from Google we will
ship it to you you can rack it in your
data center wire it up and just load it
up directly with data you can move up to
a petabyte of data on this single
appliance without having to send any
data over the network so this physical
transfer of data and then secondly we
also have a transfer service which is a
software solution which will move data
over the network and you can now you can
move it between clouds within Google
cloud and earlier this year we announced
that you could move data from
on-premises to cloud by a transfer
services on-premises so here you
download an agent it can help manage the
amount of bandwidth the network that you
want to make available to the transfer
and then manage long-running transfers
of data
to the cloud so again our goal here is
to really help customers make it as easy
as possible to bring your data home to
GCP finally I really want to highlight
our our partners so Google cloud has a
number of amazing first party products
but we also have a really great set of
partners who we work with on a number of
use cases we have a lot of customers who
are familiar with using these products
and we want to make sure they have a
great experience I and GCP and also
these partners have products that you
know do things that we just simply don't
do today we want to make sure that
customers can still have access to those
capabilities in Google cloud even if we
don't have them as first party products
so for file we've done a lot of work
with that app tell AMC to provide
integrated experiences in Google cloud
and then also with ddn to have a
marketplace experience for some high-end
the store workloads and then for backup
and disaster recovery so there are very
many companies again use familiar with
all a range of different partners here
and so we've worked a lot with all those
partners to make sure that we've
integrated closely with them to
eventually have a great experience with
jsonp and with that I would like to
thank you for listening today and say
goodbye thank you